[Musique]
bonjour et merci nous rejoindre sur tv
soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 m dont voici les titres
de ce 21 juin le département des
yvelines prévoit durant l'été soixante
dix opérations de réhabilitation au sein
de 56 collège montant global 23 millions
d'euros le point sur les chantiers à
suivre elle nous parlons également des
journées olympiques qui se déroulent ce
week-end chaque année dans le monde
entier c'est le sport qui est célébrée
fin juin un invité en plateau les
organisateurs de différents événements
prévus sur saint quentin en yvelines et
versailles et puis que retenir de la
semaine de l'agression de la présidente
de la cour d'assises de versailles au
salon du bourget en passant les épreuves
du baccalauréat l'actualité pour débuter
c'est donc la présentation par le
département des chantiers à venir dans
les collèges pas moins de 23 millions
d'euros d'investissements cet été afin
de permettre d'améliorer le cadre de vie
de renforcer la sécurité ou encore de
développer l'accès au numérique les
détails avec mélanie poker dans ce
collège triellois c'est bientôt la fin
des travaux
l'établissement se voit notamment dotés
de sanitaires pour les élèves de 6e et
d'une cage d'ascenseur
un chantier à 2 millions d'euros c'est
des rénovations qui sont programmés
depuis plusieurs années ce collège avait
besoin d'un bon coup de neuf et aussi de
travaux qu'ils vont permettre à tous les
élèves de venir
il est l'un des 56 établissements a
bénéficié de travaux durant l'été à
travers le département 70 chantiers sont
en cours ou vont débuter comme les
collèges gagarine et le village attrape
ou celui des saules à guyancourt
les travaux c'est simplement d'aller
changer complètement un bloc sanitaire
de les refaire des peintures dans les
salles de classe dalle est équipé d'une
manière numérique et plus efficace
encore que ceux qui étaient dans tel ou
tel collège où des travaux plus lourds
est des travaux d'un budget de 23
millions d'euros pour cet été 2010 9 le
département prévoit la construction
prochaine de nouveaux collèges les
travaux à mantes-la-jolie débuteront en
septembre de cette année à
vélizy-villacoublay verneuil-sur-seine
aiguillon cours à la livraison est
prévue pour 2023 et je reçois présent
deux invités sur ce plateau jean marc
freiner el mehraz
en charge des sports à versailles
bonjour et bienvenue et bienvenue
également à thierry fabre
bonjour président du vélo-club
d'elancourt saint quentin en yvelines ce
dimanche 23 juin nous allons fêter
l'olympisme à travers le monde entier et
aussi dans les yvelines une journée à
l'initiative du comité international
olympique et qui parie 2004 2024 pardon
oblige revêt en ce moment un caractère
tout particulier dans la ville de
versailles les manifestations ont
commencé dès hier et même avant-hier
avec les plus jeunes on voit revenir un
petit peu sur tout ce que vous avez pu
proposer ce sont les les scolaires le 18
juin qui ont participé à ce mouvement
olympique voilà exactement depuis donc
sur quatre jours sur cette semaine donc
on c'est un travail qui est en
continuité depuis plusieurs années donc
les scolaires habituellement font un tir
et une conclusion d'année scolaire avec
quelques épreuves sportives sur
l'emprise de montbron et depuis deux ans
donc on essaie de s'associer avec eux et
de leur apporter notre expertise et nos
moyens pour les un peu plus au delà de
ce qu'ils peuvent faire habituellement
combien d'élèves ont été mobilisés deux
établissements ça fait un peu près la
moitié des élèves de versets donc 2000
2500 élèves qui ont pu participer à ce
premier mouvement ensuite il y en a
d'autres
puisqu'au dès aujourd'hui ça s'adressait
plutôt cette fois ci au grand public ce
soir là ce soir c'est vraiment je suis
comme vous voulez c'est vous le
détailler l'un de l'autre pour ce soir
je sors ce soir là aussi c'est la
troisième fois donc on fait en sorte on
fait un relais 10 x 400 m donc sur la
piste de mont boron le soir à ce soir à
19 heures dont faisant en sorte qu' il y
ait des groupes qui s'inscrit souad
issus des clubs mais pas forcément du
club d'athlétisme trèfle ont d'autres
clubs par exemple l'an dernier un cd v
le rugby qui a gagné donc c'est donc
forcément des coureurs à pied il ya des
agents de la ville il ya des élus de la
ville et puis aussi des entreprises qui
viennent nous rejoindre et dernière une
quinzaine d'équipés donc y participer à
ceux des x 400 m à paris de 1024 oblige
versailles étant impliqué dans cette
candidature française
vous avez mis en avant les épreuves qui
seront à l'honneur pendant les jo voilà
tout à fait c'est ce qu'on essaie de
montrer depuis depuis un an surtout
autour du pentathlon puisque
pentathlon gora grande partie de ces
épreuves sur versailles et puis je
trouve que c'est un sport intéressant
puisqu'il associe plusieurs disciplines
donc ça serait intéressant qu'on peut
faire notamment avec les scolaires et
c'est ce qu'on a fait là dans les quatre
journées puisqu'ils ont pu faire de la
proche de l'escrim toujours même nom en
plein air un mont boron avec le club
local et l'athlétisme bien évidemment
aussi avec le club local
et puis aujourd'hui particulièrement que
aujourd'hui 1 le club d'équitation qui
viendra faire de l'initiation et c est
en même temps on m'associe la culture un
petit peu serre que versailles en ad des
compagnies en résidence des compagnies
de théâtre et donc avec l'une des
compagnies avec aïda aujourd'hui sans
fin tous les midis perdons tous les
midis il y avait une petite pièce à
tendance sportive autour de l'escrimé de
l'escrim des deux sièges
vous sentez déjà une certaine
effervescence autour de djo peut-être
2024 ça se concrétise un petit peu dans
l'esprit des habitants de la ville aussi
oui ça se trouverait enfin on entend les
gens commencent à intégrer les abords de
1023 c'est 2004 c'est bientôt qui se
compose beaucoup la question d où ça
sera comment ça se fera etc
et puis
ce que j'essaye d'expliquer c'est
qu'évidemment on profite de ces
événements pour pour justement aller
dans le milieu scolaire et travailler
avec les scolaires
cette année les clubs directement aussi
des prestations dans les dents dans le
temps du midi dans le temps scolaire
donc je crois ce qu'on sait c'est
intéressant donc c'est vraiment un
travail de fond notamment avec les
jeunes parce que dans cinq ans ils sont
un peu plus âgés
et puis moi je trouve d'autre part c'est
que bien évidemment on sera sollicitée
dans les années qui précèdent ou deux
ans avant pour être un un site de
reconnaissance donc sur l'équitation
comme c'est un site éphémère évidemment
il y aura pas de possibilité de venir
recevoir une équipe non aura d'autres
opportunités
je vous l'annoncé par exemple on
apporter candidature pour recevoir une
équipe pour la coupe du monde du rugby
en 2023
on va revenir vers vous dans un instant
pour parler un petit peu de cette flamme
olympique
comment vous allez l'entretenir au delà
même de ce week-end tout au long des
années prochaines
le club de vélo des longs cours 50 ans
avec vous thierry fabre est aussi
impliqué un petit peu ce week-end en
quelque sorte sur ces journées
olympiques puisque dimanche il y aura là
revancharde organisé hasard du
calendrier cela tombe pendant la
manifestation internationale olympique
et puis surtout cette colline
d'elancourt où se déroule la
manifestation soit aux sites olympiques
également alors à 12,2 à double titre
pour le club parce que comme vous le
savez c'est que on
on a le projet olympique avec paris 2024
mais on a nos pistes art parce qu'on a
comme dans le club de pistard de haut
niveau de l'équipe de france quentin
caleyron et quentin a vaqué sur le i
monde de vitesse qui fait partie des
très petits maux sociaux
donc ça déjà un projet pour le club pour
encore fidéliser cette équipe là avec du
recrutement et avoir une équipe
saint-quentinoise de saint quentin pour
représenter cinquantaine en france pour
y jouer un peu ça c'est la première
chose
la deuxième chose c'est la colonne des
encore bon ça fait 22 ans que avec le
club on organise la revancharde
avec le soutien du 10 10 78 ans narguait
aussi également des courses un
championnat de france fsgt des
championnats européens des uniformes et
organisé une cinquantaine de courses de
vtt sur ce site là ces insultes que en
fin de compte on a créé par nous mêmes
on a tracé les chemins
on a fait une amende bénévolat
en collaboration avec 50,1 de vous
laisser libre social était voilà un an à
l'abandon on va dire et cette
reconnaissance de site olympique des
jeux ce site pour paris 2024 quelqu'un
quelque part ça redis ça vient de là
revancharde sa présence dans cette
course elle n'a finalement connu donc on
est heureux de participer à cet
événement là et c'est vrai que ce site
techniquement c'est le site idéal pour
faire les jeux olympiques pourquoi parce
que c'est la montagne labine on trouve
tout sur site
la technique de pilotage des descentes
du dénivelé de la force du courage et de
la mythique pendant des jeux olympiques
alors il y aura quelques aménagements
avant les jo sur cette colline
d'elancourt ya encore deux projets qui
sont en candidature le verdict sera
donné au tour du début du mois de
juillet mi juillet nous en reparlerons
bien évidemment pour ceux qui vont venir
ce week-end connaissent pas encore la
revanchard de même si on en doute ils
vont découvrir quoi pour les spectateurs
qui vont pouvoir y assister il ya des
modifications sur le parcours ce sera
très technique très physique alors
l'origine de ceux de cette course assez
que le départ se fait au pied de la
colline et l'arrivée en haut par boucle
preuve vous serez du présent avec nous
dimanche et puis une scène nationale
france 3 sera exactement présentent ils
vont faire un reportage national est
l'origine de cette constate c'est qu'en
fin de compte quand on arrive en haut
quand les concurrents arrivent en haut
c'est la récompense la récompense de
l'effort et la récompense de la vue sur
l'île de france et je pense que ce cet
endroit là quand le sillon où ils sont
venus découvrir ce site
je pense que le rayonnement
l'image de notre pays va se faire la une
encore possible d'y participer à cette
course
oui oui on peut s'inscrire sur place
petite question parce que je parlais des
spectateurs mais j'ai oublié les
participantes ont énormément
d'inscription sur place
on a beaucoup de non licenciés saint
quentinois qui sont déjà inscrits et on
peut vous pouvez vous engager sur place
à partir de 7 heures 30 au complexe
sportif de l'europe rue de varsovie elle
encourt quartier de l'été simple hier au
pied de la colline pour suivre donc
cette revancharde que ce soit sur le
terrain en tant que participant ou alors
en tant que spectateur vous pouvez aussi
venir y assister et découvrir ce qui
sera le futur site olympique sur la
commune d'hallencourt plusieurs autres
sites sur saint quentin en yvelines sont
aussi ouverts dans le cadre des journées
de l'olympisme le 23 juin il y a le golf
national où s'est déroulée il ya
quelques temps la ryder cup il y aura
des initiations de deux proposés et puis
il ya aussi le vélodrome
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur la commune
de montigny qui proposera des
initiations aussi des démonstrations de
différents sports pas uniquement du vélo
sur piste ou encore du bmx il y aura
différents sports tout le programme est
à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
j'en reviens sur la ville de versailles
est sûre la ville de versailles il va y
avoir une montée en puissance sur ces
prochains mois prochaines années autour
de cette mobilisation pour paris 2024 et
sur l'olympisme
oui enfin j'espère que le bien sûr fin
le mouvement sportif aussi nous en parle
beaucoup ne serait ce que parce que il
les fans le cojo fera appel à beaucoup
de bénévoles de pour être présent en
accompagnement
et puis bon c'est vrai que participer en
tant que spectateur et surtout dans une
ville aussi riche comme la nôtre et on
parlait du vélo qui sera bon
essentiellement sur saint quentin mais
j'espère que le vélo sur route pour a
profité d'un passage en ville ou de
plusieurs passages en ville
vraisemblablement d'un autre côté
cette année on a fait la fête du vélo
donc on aurait essayé de se coordonner
avec toutes les villes alentour pour
avoir l'année prochaine une vraie grande
fête du vélo au mois de mai au mois de
juin et puis pourquoi pas commencer à
faire une découverte du vélo pour les
tout-petits voir une grande avenue qui
ce qui permettrait voire de le remettre
en place une course cycliste comme
c'était vrai il ya quelques années donc
je rappelle que si vous voulez vous
plonger dans l'esprit olympique 1 en
marge de la fête de la musique c'est dès
aujourd'hui du côté de de versailles et
puis dimanche vous pourrez aussi
découvrir celui ce site de la revanche
hard as du côté des longs cours merci à
tous les deux d'être venus si vous
voulez les tout le programme complet des
manifestations organisées dans le cadre
des journées olympique rendez vous sur
le site internet du ministère des sports
merci à vous deux on passe à présent
résumé de la semaine
[Musique]
l'actualité à lundi avec l'une des
présidente de la cour d'assises des
yvelines qui a été blessé à son domicile
par deux hommes touchés par un tir mme
d'armes dont identifié qui pourrait être
un lanceur de balles de défense la
section de recherches de la gendarmerie
de versailles tente de retrouver deux
personnes pour la tentative d'assassinât
à la réaction du syndicat unité
magistrat fo par la voix de sa
secrétaire général on les écoute ce que
l'on demande aujourd'hui c'est de
prendre toute la mesure de cette
agression pour en profiter pour faire le
point et recenser toutes les menaces et
tous les outrages que des magistrats
subie au sein de leurs fonctions de
faire un état des lieux
les dispositifs de sécurité de leur
pertinence de faire un état des lieux
aussi des plaintes qui ont été déposées
par les magistrats parce que
malheureusement les magistrats ont
plutôt tendance à ne pas déposer plainte
et voir pourquoi
et puis voir aussi comment la hiérarchie
met en place des systèmes de protection
réelle sur des magistrats qui sont
exposés à l'actualité de cette semaine
c'est aussi le baccalauréat ouverture en
début de semaine pour toutes les séries
par les traditionnelles épreuves de
philosophie écouter à les réactions à
des candidats ils sont quelque 740 3594
à travers la france on notera également
que les appels à la grève des
enseignants contre la réforme et du
ministre de l'éducation ont été assez
peu suivie dans notre département
selon vous le travail difficile les
hommes est ce que le travail divisé les
hommes
je pourrais dire que on a deux parties
oui oui et non il travaille difficile
les hommes
non pas forcément le travail difficile
elle les hommes si le sujet inspire
moyennement les yvelinois ils étaient
plus de 20 mille candidats de la filière
économique et sociale dans les yvelines
devoir s'y pencher ce lundi matin lundi
17 juin l'ouverture de la nouvelle
session du baccalauréat par la
traditionnelle épreuve de philosophie
j'ai juste appris ma cour j'essaie de
comprendre parce que pour moi la
philosophie va comprendre par là contre
parker se sert à rien à part la
définition on a toujours l'impression de
pas être assez préparé donc on croise
les doigts et on pourra la bonne chance
parmi les autres sujets proposés elle
les lois peuvent elles faire notre
bonheur où la pluralité des cultures
fait l obstacle à l'unité du genre
humain
ce que j'ai sous les yeux c'est le sujet
ds très beau sujet vraiment ces trois
sujets j'aurais eu ben à choisir entre
les trois sont vraiment des
belles choses avec des diversités fin
des sujets qui sont divers qui font
appel à des références très variés et
sur lesquels je pense que les élèves
peuvent vraiment faire d excellente
copie 70 1944 candidates et candidats se
présentent dans les yvelines au
baccalauréat dont un peu moins de 30000
dans les séries technologiques et
professionnelles et après 4 heures
d'épreuve la confiance le dispute comme
toujours au soulagement ça s'est bien
passé
actuellement ça va je pense qu'il me
suis bien débrouillé après c'est vrai
qu'on l'a appréhendé la philo ça faisait
un moment est bon la philo c'est pas
quelque chose de simple donc forcément
on a dû faire avec mais franchement je
pense que ça s'est bien passé
franchement ça va il était facile mais
mon prof m'a dit j'aurais pas plus de
huit ans psg mais je pensais bonnes
notes 3 de la philo prochaine épreuve
l'histoire-géographie mardi matin suivis
par les langues mercredi résultats
attendus le 5 juillet politiques et
élections municipales à guyancourt avec
un nouveau candidat rodolphe baril se
présente sans étiquette après avoir été
pendant plusieurs années adjoint au
maire dans une majorité de droite dans
une commune voisine il sera notamment
face à françois morton le maire divers
gauche sortant en place depuis quelques
mois après le départ demain et christine
le tarnec pour raisons de santé
rodolphe baril qui étaient en plateau
mardi su pourquoi vous lancer à
guyancourt
pourquoi but en cours parce que d'abord
j'y suis donc pourquoi pas c'est pas
parce qu'on a été élu dans une autre
commune qu'on ne peut pas
se présenter dans une eau dans une autre
commune mais ça peut apporter aussi une
certaine expérience tout à fait en fait
on peut le voir de manière positive
dire que j'ai une certaine expérience
donc aujourd'hui je vais mettre
l'expérience que j'ai au profit des
gluants pour toi on a un dossier qui est
assez important que c'est alex par
exemple le projet thales
c'est aussi redonner m billancourt au
coeur de au coeur de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est quand ils ont réussi aujourd'hui à
se fâcher avec avec avec la communauté
d'agglomération faut pas oublier que la
communauté d'agglomération aujourd'hui
gère à la compétence 50 % de ce qui se
passe sur toutes les communes donc
aujourd'hui vous prenez thales par
exemple qui est un gros projet sur
guyancourt une ville de guyancourt n'a
plus la compétence parce qu'ils ont
réussi à se fâcher avec tout le monde et
à faire en sorte que le préfet donne
cette compétence à le pap est ce cette
semaine nous avons aussi commémoré à
l'appel du 18 juin 79 ans que le général
de gaulle a prononcé son discours sur
les ondes de la bbc à londres appelant à
ne pas déposer les armes face à
l'allemagne nazie une cérémonie commune
comme c'est le cas depuis plusieurs
années elle s'est tenue vous le voyez
entre coignard maurepas et le mesnil
saint denis s'était devant le monument
de la malmö d'hommes et cette année les
enfants étaient associés au devoir de
mémoire
je crois que c'est important que les
jeunes à plus forte raison parce que les
témoins disparaissent les uns après les
autres et il est important d associer à
ces moments où on se souvient ensemble
puisque c'est la définition même d'une
commémoration et je pense que l'on on
leur transmet alors je ne sais pas si on
leur transmet l'histoire mon leur
transmet au moins des émotions voilà une
démarche qui est mémorielle qui est
utile pour les jeunes générations de
comprendre l'appel du général de gaulle
son contexte le fond de sa pensée et
surtout voilà l'appel à la résistance
pour combattre l'allemagne nazie donc sa
part évidemment d'une bonne démarche
qu'il faut continuer dans l'avenir un
tout autre sujet à présent le 53e salon
international de l'aéronautique et de l
espace a ouvert ses portes cette semaine
c'est au bourget en seine-saint-denis un
événement qui rassemble aussi des
entreprises du secteur de saint quentin
en yvelines une trentaine d'entreprises
sont présentes sur place et elle
travaille sur notamment sur les moteurs
du futur patrick jacques de dixmude et
nicolas landry des taxis volant à
l'énergie électrique des avions
fonctionnant avec des moteurs hybrides
des innovations présentées sur ce salon
du goût
les 2019 par l'équipementier
aéronautique français
le groupe safran des technologies en
évolution permanente
on peut pas dire aujourd'hui que
l'airbus a320 que vous prenez pour aller
en vacances sera totalement électrique
dans dix ans certainement pas en
revanche pour des véhicules beaucoup
plus petit donc on entend beaucoup
parler
la mobilité à la demande mais aussi des
avions comme hutter aux régionaux de
quelques dizaines de passagers
eh bien les technologies pour être prête
beaucoup plus vitry le projet du moteur
électrique et hybride est développée
notamment par safran tech basée à magny
les hameaux
un centre de recherche du groupe
inauguré en 2015
alors on travaille effectivement sur
comment rendre un moteur plus
électriques pour les avions de transport
de passagers
ces technologies là permettent des gains
de carburant mais aussi des gains
d'efficacité en opération des coups de
coude usage par l'électrification et
l'assistance électrique en fait du
moteur classique c'est l'incontournable
du salon du bourget le rafale l'avion de
combat de l'armée française omnirôle
développé par dassault aviation
un appareil composé de pièces fabriquées
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas de cette antenne usiné par
le groupe bauer et sa filiale jacques
loupé cli en collaboration avec thales
ce sont des systèmes de détection son
appel de la guerre électronique et donc
ils permettent de détecter des cibles
pour protéger en fait tu leur as far et
de systèmes da nous sommes en pleine
croissance actuellement en l'espace de
cinq ans gwen a doublé et nous avons la
même perspective pour les 5 10
prochaines années
au total près de 60 entreprises
aéronautiques sont implantés sur saint
quentin en yvelines pour quatorze mille
emplois dans le secteur
ce vendredi à 21 juin premier jour de
l'été nous célébrons également la
musique événement qui se prolongera tout
au long du week-end dans certaines
communes des yvelines et c'est le cas
notamment aux clayes-sous-bois avec les
clés si belle ce sera gratuit à partir
de 15 heures avec de nombreux groupes
débutants aux confirmés earth wind and
fire culture à d'ailleurs cette soirée
et puis un enfant de la commune sera
aussi présent révélée dans the voice
vincent vinel j'avais à dire sept bébés
du village mais n'ont pas pas vraiment
mais en tout cas c'est voilà c'est un
jeune qui est qui qui a vraiment une vie
que les siennes depuis tout petits qui
acquit à qui a vécu aussi dans nos
structures et puis qui est devenu un
artiste complet qu'a fait mon café the
voice à cette une
c'est une étape mais depuis c'est le
tremplin
depuis il a fait du cinéma voilà et puis
on a fait quelques grosses scènes déjà
et puis nous fait ce cadeau parce que
c'est vraiment ça de de venir se
produire dans sa ville quoi c'est à la
fois un grand plaisir pour lui puis
c'est vraiment un super cadeau pour nous
que les siens on attendre en plus il va
nous faire des surprises des nouveaux
titres voilà donc on est ravi et pour le
programme complet dans le département en
rendez vous sur notre site internet pour
consulter les replays et du 7-8 culture
et 7,8 loisirs de cette semaine à chaque
semaine nous vous proposons aussi de
faire le point sur le reste de
l'actualité en ile-de-france avec nos
confrères de via grand paris diffusée
sur le canal 36 de la tnt est
aujourd'hui focus sur le prolongement à
de la cèze dès cet automne l'autoroute
baptisé l'européenne
elle sera à connecter à la francilienne
à l'automne prochain
cette voie longue de trois kilomètres
encore en travaux sera connectée à la
francilienne en direction de
roissy-charles de gaulle il s'agit de la
nouvelle section de l'autoroute a16
c'est l'un des trois secteurs de ce
gigantesque chantier commencé en 2016
est évalué à 210 millions d'euros
l'un des objectifs
détourner le trafic de l'actuelle
nationale 1 qui traverse les communes de
maffliers mon souffle
il ya environ quarante mille véhicules
jour qui passe sur cet axe là donc c'est
du trafic qui est plus tôt
le soir et le matin c'est du travail et
trafic domicile travail dont quarante
mille véhicules jour il y en a environ
35000 qui seront reportés sur l'a16 et
5000 reste qui resteront sur l'ancienne
nationale rin dans mon fils et ma fille
fin juin la transformation de l'actuelle
nationale 1 en autoroute sera achevée
elle assurera le prolongement de l'a16
entre l'isle adam et la croix verte
l'autre enjeu du chantier restaurer la
continuité de la francilienne entre
cergy et roissy charles de gaulle le
fameux giratoire de la croix verte
désormais disparu du paysage
les travaux là aussi touche bientôt à
leur fin
donc là on est au niveau de la croix
verte à l'emplacement de l'ancien
giratoire on a construit la nouvelle
plateforme de la francilienne et depuis
la mi mai les usagers en provenance de
cergy qui aideront à roissy peuvent
emprunter la nouvelle plateforme qui
enjambe le pont qui a été réalisée le
sens inverse roissy cergy sera mis en
service à la mi chemin le reste du
chantier sera quant à lui terminé fin
il s'agira de connecter les dernières
bretelles comme la cèze à la rd 301 en
direction de paris autour de la
francilienne
les huit rond point aménagé pour
desservir les départementales alentours
et les communes voisines déjà bien
avancés seront eux aussi achevé avant de
refermer cette hebdo nous allons nous
plonger dans les archives de tv 78 avec
notre rubrique habituel ça s'est passé
en juillet à 2010 est celle landais
futur champion de rugby avec toulouse
sofiane guitoune était en pleine
rééducation à clairefontaine dans les
yvelines
là deux ans plus tard il s'apprête
également maintenant à retrouver
l'équipe de france
[Musique]
un rugbyman du stade toulousain au pays
des footballeurs sofiane guitoune
travail avec maxence piaule et
préparateur physique du centre médical
de clairefontaine accélération sur 20
mètres changements d'appuis et de
vitesse des exercices pour solliciter
les adducteurs du sportif l'objectif
était vraiment de le recentrer sur ses
sensations et pour voir si lui santé un
déséquilibre au niveau du cycle des
genres mois antérieur sofiane guitoune
28 ans trois quarts polyvalent du stade
toulousain 5 sélections dans le quinze
de france une participation aux jeux
olympiques de rio en 2016 avec l'équipe
de france à 7
depuis plusieurs semaines il effectue sa
rééducation au centre médical de
clairefontaine après avoir contracté une
pubalgie il ya deux ans il se fait
opérer une première fois en début
d'année à la paroi abdominale
malgré l'intervention la douleur est
toujours présente du coup quand je me
suis fait opérer à fin fin avril le
chirurgien m'a parlé de clairefontaine
et c'était possible de venir faire sa
rééducation ici et que voilà que c'était
le domaine des footeux que
j'avais l'habitude de donner ce genre de
blessure ma vie c'est vraiment une
blessure difficile à gérer il ya des
hauts et des bas et pour faut faire avec
c'est jamais tout rose et voilà la
semaine dernière ça va très très bien en
début de semaine c'était un peu
compliqué là ça va mieux après le
terrain place au renforcement musculaire
une rééducation d'une trentaine d'heures
par semaine suivie de près par le staff
du stade toulousain
une harmonisation des charges de travail
entre le centre médical de
clairefontaine et le club des soins pour
une meilleure récupération on va à la
fois s'occuper de ses parois et de céder
de ses adducteurs
donc le but c'est vraiment de
réharmoniser la zone le centre médical
existe depuis onze ans on retrouve des
consultations pour tous les sportifs
qu'ils soient amateurs ou professionnels
la section rééducation destiné aux
sportifs de haut niveau
priorité aux footballeurs mais pas
seulement rugbyman basketteurs
handballeurs ou même danseur de
breakdance
donc on essaye
voilà d'avoir de la diversité et ce qui
est intéressant pour tout le monde c'est
bien pour nous pour varier un petit peu
le type de pathologie le type d'exercice
à mettre en place
le séjour de sofiane guitoune à
clairefontaine se termine ce jeudi 13
juillet reprise de l'entraînement avec
le stade toulousain à la fin du mois
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivis retour de
l'actualité lundi en direct 18h avec
grégory canal est excellent week end
[Musique]
oui